- [Alan] You're an
outspoken advocate for
both hustle and self-awareness.
- [Gary] Yes.
- But if you had
to put them in order,
even if it's a 1A and 1B--
- [Gary] Self-awareness.
- Self-awareness.
- [Gary] And
it's not even close.
Yes, when you know who
you are, hustle is sexier.
- [Alan] Yeah.
- Like it would've be cooler for
like the people listening for me
to say hustle
'cause it's cooler.
- [Alan] Mhmmm.
- Self-awareness is the game.
So, I love sports.
I don't play a lot.
I'm old now, I'm 40.
I try to play.
I wish we could've
played this morning.
- [Alan] Yeah.
- I'm sorry I had to miss it but
what you would've noticed very
quickly is I have
no left hand because
I didn't have older brothers.
I didn't have anybody
teaching me to go to,
like when my brother, AJ's a
much better player because when
he was nine I forced him to only
play lefty which allowed him to
have both sides of the ball.
I'm self-aware that
I don't have a left hand.
One of the reasons I don't get
the ball stolen so much and when
you play pickup basketball is
I try not to go that direction
that much if somebody's
smart and paying attention,
they'll recognize it by game two
or three and they'll be able to
defend me better.
But when you know
yourself, you win.
In business, the reason I've
been so successful is I know
what I'm good at and
I know what I'm not good at.
- [Alan] Yeah.
- And so when you
actually understand yourself.
You know how many people are
listening right now that love
athletics and think they have
a jump shot and think they can
take it to the rack.
- [Alan] You see it daily.
- That's right and instead of
taking a step back and saying
I suck going to my left
and then working on it--
- [Alan] Yep.
- they continue to bullshit
themselves and they never excel.
Self-awareness in sports is that
and in business it's people that
think they're good a marketer
or it's somebody who thinks that
they're good at selling or it's
somebody who thinks they're good
at HR or being a leader and the
truth is you may not be and
I think you look at,
I'm friendly
with Draymond Green.
- [Alan] Yeah.
- His self-awareness has made
him a much better basketball
player because he
knew what he was good at.
- [Alan] Yeah.
- And Tom Izzo did a great,
does a great job with that
if you look at why Michigan.
You know this better than I do,
I'm just dangerous enough
to add to this conversation.
- [Alan] Of course.
- He puts players in a
position to succeed then
the whole team is better.
You know and so, my friends,
if you're listening right now,
if you just know who you are,
if you know that you're short,
if you know that your fast,
if you know that you can shoot,
if you know that
you're a good guy,
your patient gal,
if you know who you are and
do more of that and then also
understand whether you need to
work on those weaknesses or not.
So for example in business,
I think actually not working on
your weaknesses is a good
strategy because you hire or
partner up around it.
The problem with basketball
is, just being cliché here is,
if never work in your left
hand you're never gonna have it.
- [Alan] Right.
- So, you know, and it limits
you so I think self-awareness is
the single most
important drug in society.
- [Alan] Wow.
Why do most people lack it?
Is it ignorance or fear?
- Bot, I think it's
a lot of things.
- [Alan] Most people
are not self-aware.
I'll be fully transparent.
I wasn't self-aware 'til about
three years ago when I went
through counseling for a divorce
and it completely
transformed my life.
You seem like someone that's
been self-aware forever so
I guess the first part of the
question is how long have you
been self-aware and
where did that come from?
And then the second is
why isn't everybody else?
- You know, it's
funny I think and this gets
into a whole 'nother thing.
I wonder if true
self-confidence,
like true, is
actually the unlock.
I think I've been self-aware a
long time because I had crazy
self-confidence
when I shouldn't have.
- [Alan] Yeah, okay.
- When you're a freshman in
high school and you're 4-11 and
you're book bag
is bigger than you,
you shouldn't be as
confident as I was.
(Alan laughs)
Do you know what I mean?
And that goes back to great
parenting and that is I think
the reason I've over-indexed
in the business world is
I think people see my purity.
Which is I want to be the best.
- [Alan] Yep.
- But I don't want it
at your expense.
- [Alan] Right.
- I just want to be the
best and if I'm not Mazel Tov,
you're better
congratulations and if I am,
I'm gonna to
stick in your mouth.
- [Alan] Yeah.
- And I'm gonna talk shit
and I'm gonna fucking own it.
I'm gonna love it, right?
- [Alan] Love it.
- But if you beat me
like this last week
we went to
Chattanooga, Tennessee.
We played the Bellhops guys from
a startup down there and the
Vayner guys we lost all five
games and I'm pissed and
I hate them and hope their
company goes out of business--
- [Alan] Yeah.
- but I give them respect they
won and listen when you have a
6-7 walk on Auburn when playing
pickup basketball you're gonna
lose but I think the punchline
is I respect the game
even at my own expense.
- [Alan] Yeah.
- I don't want
to be a hypocrite.
I think there's DNA,
I think there's parenting,
I think there's
a lot of variables.
If you didn't get lucky
with the right environment,
you didn't get lucky
with the right parents,
it's gonna be harder for you.
I think I was blessed.
I do think I was lucky.
I believe that.
It doesn't take away
the fact that is true.
- [Alan] Right.
- You know,
like people say,
"Well, you're lucky."
Fine but it's true.
People say, "Oh, you're
a white male in society.
"You have it better."
You're right but it doesn't
change what's happening.
- [Alan] Doesn't
change the outcome.
- I think too many
people get romantic about
the way they want it.
So I was in Birmingham,
Alabama and somebody said,
"Hey, gentrification's
happening,
"how do we let
minorities win in business?"
I'm like, "Win in business."
- [Alan] Yeah.
- And I used basketball,
I go, "How do we get more
white players in the NBA?
"They have to be good."
- [Alan] Yeah.
- The market is the
market is the market.
- [Alan] It's the only way.
- The market is the
market is the market.
And so I would tell you going on
the life kick right now nobody
cares about your problems.
I just have bad
news for everybody,
nobody cares that you
don't have time to practice.
Nobody cares that you
didn't grow up with money.
came from a bad neighborhood.
As a matter of fact, you
know who I think's in the worst
position in
startup business world?
Rich white kids
'cause they're fucking soft.
- [Alan] Yeah.
- And they've been pampered and
private schools and Ivy League
school and become a sort of
business in the market says
I don't care
who your mama was.
- [Alan] Right.
- I don't care what daddy.
Daddy can't donate to
the market to make you win.
Got it?
- [Alan] Got it.
- And that's why
my kid, for example,
Xander Vaynerchuk
if you're listening,
you're four years old you
will not score a basket at home.
The reason you have zero baskets
on me is 'cause the market's not
to treat you any different than
daddy's treating you right now
so if you listening to this
right in recall and you're 13
and you're plotting how you're
gonna beat me on one on one
telling you right now,
nine years from now,
I'm 49 I'm in the best shape
of my life and I'mma beat your
fucking ass until
you can actually beat me.
- [Alan] Yeah,
but when he does,
it'll be real and
it'll be pure--
- That's why AJ's a
better player than me.
AJ's when he
beat me at 16 or 17,
first of all,
it tasted delicious.
- [Alan] Yes.
- And second of all,
it's because he became a
better player and now I work
my face off to try to beat him.
- [Alan] Yeah.
Awesome.
Hustle and hard work
are they synonyms or
is there a difference?
I know you tend to
use the word hustle more.
- Yeah, I think they're
slang and the same thing.
I mean look, guys, nobody's
been successful on pure talent.
- [Alan] Correct.
- Right?
Again, I'm being very sport
here 'cause I love sports and
I love the basketball stuff.
If that was the case the number
one pick in the NBA draft would
always be a superstar.
- [Alan] Right.
- It's not just talent.
It's why all these, it's why the
NBA draft is such a crapshoot.
People look at
intangibles and talent too much.
- [Alan] Yeah.
- That's why Draymond can go
in the second round when it was
black and white he was
the heart of the team and
he was gonna be a good player.
Like it's just real.
- [Alan] Yeah.
- There's a lot more Draymonds
and Wayne Chrebets
than you realize.
They just come in
different shapes and sizes.
They don't have to be,
Wayne Chrebets
insanity, football.
- [Alan] Yep.
- Draymond's a second round
pick so it's not that insane.
It comes like, pick 11.
Why is Steph not
number one overall?
You know it went to Davis.
The intangibles, the speed,
this and that but you can't
judge heart and the intangibles
are everything in
life and hard work.
- [Alan] Yeah.
- There's way too many people
that give up under adversity
especially when
they've had it easy.
If you're an NBA player
or if you're a whiz kid,
business kid that went to good
schools you've had it so easy.
What happens
when they punch you?
You know that leap from
college star to NBA star?
Hard core.
- [Alan] Yeah.
- That's a
whole different world.
A lot of those kids fail 'cause
they got punched in
the mouth the first time.
They were the best
player in middle school.
- [Alan] Without a doubt.
- Best player in high school and
they were even the best player
in college and then they
get to the pros and they lose.
You know, back to business,
a lot of these kids lose 'cause
they never were the best player.
They were the fake best player.
They were the best student.
- [Alan] Yeah.
- Great, you got an
A in business class.
That shit is bullshit.
That's like me
being good at NBA 2K.
- [Alan] Right.
- That's fake.
What happens when you
actually start a business?
So, I make a lot of parallels
from business and sports and
I do think hustle is actually
one of the two core...
ingredients.
- [Alan] Yeah.
- It is hard work and
hustle/talent that's the
formula, always and forever.
'Cause timing is talent.
You can force
yourself in to any timing.
I know that
meditation's gonna be big.
I know that e-sports
are going to be big.
That's not timing, that's
my talent of observing consumer
behavior and making bets.
I didn't get lucky.
I didn't have a talent for that.
I'm pointing at my
Twitter and Tumblr stock.
Right?
- [Alan] Right.
- That wasn't luck.
That wasn't timing.
That was the world is going
to be all about social media.
I'm gonna invest in
Facebook, Twitter, Tumblr.
That was talent.
That was understanding
where humans were gonna be.
- [Alan] So by your
definition of talent,
how much of it is something
you're born with and how much of
it is you pounding--
- Born!
- [Alan] craft?
- Born and then the
hard work is banging away.
- [Alan] Okay.
- Like I had people intuition
but I may be didn't deploy in
a business world and then
I was just right about trends
and I can always be on my
bowling team be like I knew
Uber was to be big but
I didn't do anything about it.
- [Alan] Right.
- I didn't deploy it.
That was just intuition that
I was just a good guy at
the bar, you know, got it?
- [Alan] Absolutely.
- Talent is real, guys.
- [Alan] Oh for sure.
- Like you see it every day.
Go look at third
graders playing basketball.
I don't know how young
you go or what you see.
Like it's there.
I was making money as a
six-year-old selling lemonade
and then baseball cards.
I didn't read a business book.
I was six.
There was no time
to hone my talent.
It was in me then
I put in the work every day.
You know, I associate
with athletes because
I punted school too.
Just so everybody knows,
everybody who's made the league
in whatever league, they stopped
caring about algebra and science
somewhere around second grade.
I was the same.
I got Ds and Fs my whole life
because I knew was gonna be a
businessman and long before
businessmen and entrepreneurs
were gonna be cool,
I fought the system.
I had the
self-esteem to pull it off.
I thought my
teachers were wrong.
I knew I wasn't a loser.
You know I'm an '80s, '90s kid
when education
was the whole game.
There was no entrepreneurship
and I fought the market and did
my thing and it
worked out for me.
- [Alan] What guides your
decision making mostly now?
Is it instinct or experience?
- Legacy.
- [Alan] Ah!
- I make most my
decisions now based on
what is it gonna
mean to my legacy.
It's quite vain, actually.
It's me writing the history of
my life in real time but a lot
of it comes from legacy.
- [Alan] Love it.
- I want to know
how people think about,
you know how nice it
is to hear your intro?
Do you know how, like somebody
tweeted that they think I'm a
good guy because of the
things they've heard from you.
- [Alan] Yes.
- See one of the great things
is the truth is undefeated.
Doing the right thing
is always the right thing.
- [Alan] Love that.
- I have no idea who you
influence or who you know but
just doing the right thing by
anybody you come across you just
never know and so I like a
good, I want a good legacy.
- [Alan] It's
like telling the truth.
If you always tell the truth
then you don't have to worry
about what web you've created.
- Yeah.
- [Alan] Last
question for you, my friend.
I'm guessing you started
VaynerMedia 'cause you saw a
void in the digital media space.
Is that why you
started VaynerSports?
- It's not why I
started VaynerMedia.
- [Alan] Oh, okay.
- And it's not why I
started of VaynerSports.
I started VaynerMedia because
I wanted to build the greatest
marketing machine of all-time
then buy businesses and
run it through it.
- [Alan] Okay.
- I didn't realize how horrible
the other agencies were at
digital and specifically
social marketing and that's
why got to build a very
big company out of
lack of competition.
- [Alan] Okay.
- No joke, even though it
seems like a competitive space.
As far as VaynerSports,
oh God, what a
potpourri of circumstances.
I basically was wearing a weird
Jets jersey that that
somebody took a picture of.
The agent of that player hit me
up we created a relationship,
he had a very small
agency called Symmetry Sports.
We became friendly.
He had his own
business dynamics.
In parallel on top of that
narrative that I'm telling you,
my brother AJ
has Crohn's disease,
he wanted to get out of
VaynerMedia 'cause it is a lot
of pressure and he
didn't like it anymore.
That other guy Mook calls
me one they randomly and says,
"Do you want to
buy my sports agency?"
I'm thinking in the back of my
head maybe this is something me
and AJ can do once he's
out of Vayner in a year.
Doesn't seem like that much
and then I said yes as an
entrepreneur and then what's
happened so I went with my
intuition and now I'm realizing
oh my God these kids are not
being I mean whoa...
I mean these agents are not, you
know and I know I don't want to
be unfair and paint
everybody the same way.
- [Alan] Right.
- But a stunning percentage of
these agents really don't give a
crap about these kids.
It's a meat market.
They could care less.
What if I did what I did
in the wine business and the
advertising and startup world?
What if I care
more than everybody?
I have a feeling that caring
more in this business actually's
gonna give me even more legs.
Do know what my dream is?
If and when, and
I think it's when,
when we do the NBA, I'm gonna
stay in that genre 'cause we're
doing NFL first.
- [Alan] Yep.
- That I get the number four
pick in the NBA draft and he has
a Paul George like injury
and never plays in preseason.
Never plays, fourth pick in the
draft and then I take care of
that kid for the rest my life.
Help them learn business.
Work with him.
Get them into startup.
Write a book
about his adversity.
Build a podcast around
him like change his life.
Have a, show the world what
I'm really doing here which is
anybody that signs with
VaynerSports it's for life.
- [Alan] Yeah.
- That was me
spitting into my hand.
- [Alan] Love it.
- It's everything.
It's everything.
This kid right here.
Vernon Adams one
of our first clients
when I bought into the agency.
It still says Symmetry team as
you see on the jersey up here.
He didn't get drafted.
He was supposed to go in the
fifth or sixth round but I guess
the NFL deemed
them too undersized.
He crushed at Oregon
for anybody listening.
Then he doesn't get
UDF aid which was stunning.
Where is he now?
The CFL and we spent a lot of
money to put them in the right
position to succeed on
a $500 commission check.
- [Alan] Always do right.
- Always do right
'cause he's the best dude.
His family's the best and
I still think he's gonna do a
Warren Moon and Doug Flutie and
come in the NFL and dominate and
it's gonna feel
better than ever.
And if it doesn't, that's just
the way the market reacted and
I just know that
we'll do anything we can
to do right by him.
So I think in the, I hope
when I die that some of
the conversations
around my death are,
"Well, he changes the sports
industry forever because when he
"started VaynerSports
with the other guys what Mook,
"Brian, AJ and Gary did at
VaynerSports was they took care
"of players in such a
way it forced Rock Nation,
"it forced CAA,
it forced Drew Rosenhaus,
"it forced Doug Conna, it forced
all these people to care more
"just to compete with them and
it changed the market forever."
I love that legacy.
- [Alan] That's
a hell of a legacy.
Thank you so much for your time.
- Thanks for having me, boss.
- [Alan] I appreciate
you, brother.
- Love you, man.